hi I'm Alicia Malone and even though I
am alone yep totally single I've watched
a lot of romantic movies so I feel
completely qualified to tell you how to
throw the perfect wedding according to
the movie step 1 choose your wedding
party carefully putting together the
right bridal party can be tricky you
want your groomsmen to be up for some
fun but hopefully not too much fun
as for the bridesmaids try not to choose
a maid of honor who is secretly hatching
a plan to steal your groom step 2 vet
your guests
I know it's your big day and you'll
probably want to invite as many people
as possible but beware not all wedding
guests follow traditional wedding
etiquette which includes not being
obsessed with your new bride and trying
to steal her no matter how sweet it may
seem with a British accent then of
course there are the wedding crashers
they sneak in
eat your food drink your booze and
sleaze onto your guests though within
the context of a movie it actually can
be quite sweet step 3
entertainment at a wedding entertainment
can come in many forms sometimes it's
planned like a rockin band and other
times well not so much be sure that the
person who will be performing the
ceremony can actually pronounce the
ceremony and be sure that the best man
actually has your best interests in mind
of course if all else fails you can say
get and head to the dance floor and
finally step 4 run away
I mean if movies have taught me anything
they've taught me this just run run away
it's not too late or maybe it is perhaps
I'm not actually qualified to be giving
all this advice those are my tips on how
to plan the perfect wedding according to
the movie so just follow them and before
you know it well there's always the
honeymoon
[Music]